Ми намагалися реагувати на те,
що є величезна потреба
в гуманітарній допомозі на Сході,
ми поїхали туди волонтерити, допомагати людям.
У результаті — створилася така програма
«Будуємо Україну разом»,
яка зараз мандрує вже різними містами України,
допомагає людям у потребах.
Також ми створюємо ці молодіжні осередки,
молодіжні центри, як-от «Вільна хата».
І це є інша величезна програма —
«Львівська освітня фундація».
Зараз ми в одному зі спальних
районів Львова — у Рясне,
сьогодні останній день нашого туру Україною
з новоствореним БУРмобілем.
Ми, разом із нашими партнерами
з команди «Острів» із Києва,
створили першу в Україні мобільну майстерню,
яка стала можливою завдяки
близько 500 людям із України і з цілого світу,
які зібрали кошти для того, щоб ми могли
ефективніше працювати в локальних громадах,
створювати громадські простори,
молодіжні центри.
І от зараз вже, упродовж останнього місяця,
ми мандруємо різними містами України.
Почали з Києва, [відвідали] Харків,
Одесу, Чернівці, Ужгород, Мукачево,
доїхали, нарешті, до Львова.
У майбутньому цей БУРмобіль
мандруватиме на табори,
він буде теж як промоційний
інструмент для того,
щоб розказувати місту, що в ньому
зараз працює волонтерський табір,
що приїхало 25 крутих людей
із цілої України, і з інших країн,
і вони створюють у місті громадський простір,
і ви можете сюди приходити,
долучатись,  допомагати.
Багато людей зауважує
і питає про наше сімейне виховання: «Як ми росли?».
Я так проаналізував, можливо,
декілька ключових факторів,
які можливо сприяли тому,
що я чи мої брати, сестри
залучені в певні громадські,
соціальні проєкти.
Ну, думаю, що насамперед
це дуже активна позиція нашого тата.
Він був у «Товаристві Лева»,
був одним із учасників
Революції на граніті 1990-го року,
і коли, до прикладу відбувалася
Помаранчева революція,
він теж їздив на Майдан, і нам це все розказував,
і ми у тому розумінні важливості
брати участь виростали.
Ну і потім, паралельно з тим всім,
ми фактично виростали в середовищі УКУ.
Тобто тато був першим випускником УКУ,
потім працював там, і ми якось
постійно в тій спільноті перебували,
і сам приклад, прецедент УКУ
як першого досить успішного,
незалежного навчального закладу в Україні,
який створився завдяки підтримці
тисяч людей із України, і з цілого світу.
І, мабуть, воно нас формувало
як проактивних громадян,
які розуміють, що треба особисто долучатись,
щоб у цій країні стало краще жити.
Привіт!
І нас знімає мільйон камер.
Це наша Аглайка —
наречена нашого брата Павла,
а це Павло — наш молодший брат.
— А ми молочко привезли.
— Ого!
Молочко козяче привезли.
— Взяла в тітки Люби.
— То козяче.
Дай спробувати, я ніколи козяче не пив.
Клас! Прекрасне просто молоко.
— А я не буду тоді «меее» робити?
— Я не знаю.
Ой, як гарно! Клас!
Це наймолодша сестричка Ганнуся.
Вона закінчила
Українську академію лідерства рік тому,
і вступила в УКУ, пішла моїм шляхом
на історичний факультет.
— Історикиня буду.
— Історикиня, так.
І вона також
членкиня спільноти GLC.
Girls' Leadership Community
— Хто ти ще? Пластунка, художниця.
— Пластунка.
— Художниця.
— Мисткиня, співачка.
Співачка, танцівниця. Все. Думаю, досить.
[сміються]
Це Натуська наша — одна з двійнят.
Вона теж закінчила УАЛ, перший випуск.
Зараз вчиться в УКУ на соціальній педагогіці,
і, до речі, планує мандрівку в Гондурас
на річне служіння в спільноті...
— Як?
— «Дім серця».
«Дім серця». Тому я рік її не бачитиму.
Галя — друга з двійнят.
У принципі біографія та сама:
закінчила УАЛ, пластунка, танцівниця.
— Що?
— Мисткиня.
— Ні, танцюєш так собі, але краще за мене.
— Ну, деколи.
Вчиться зараз на соціології в УКУ,
дуже активна, була, до речі, донедавна
президенткою студентського самоврядування УКУ,
головою студентського братства.
Тож так. Вона теж у тій сфері
громадських активістів.
— По Юркових слідах.
— Так, по моїх слідах.
Наш тато вирішив зробити такий бізнес,
і ми його назвали «Дивокаяк».
І ми тепер робимо різні сплави на різні тематики:
реколекційні, відпочинкові, з лекціями.
Словом, суперцікаво.
Те, що кожен щось робить, —
це як виклик для когось іншого.
У нас, коли ти щось не робиш,
то почуваєшся поза сім'єю, поза цінностями.
Ну, звичайно, може це не так,
але для нас таким взірцем творення,
я думаю все ж таки, з дітей є старший  брат.
Він справді в нас — старший брат.
Задав високу планку.
Так. І він задав своїми проєктами, своєю життєвою позицією,
цінностями, таку планку для всіх нас.
І за це йому вдячні,
і всяко долучаємось до БУРу.
Тут кожен якось був і учасником БУРу,
я на початках знімав відео перші БУРу,
хоча як проєкт-місію
я вважаю свій «Вільний простір».
«Вільний простір» — це спроба створити альтернативу гуртожиткам.
Це спільнота, у якій живе до 15-ти людей,
і є правила гри, які залучають до активності.
І ми, власне, позиціонуємо,
що «Вільний простір» є осередком-спільнотою,
де би мали розвиватися
і зберігатися такі цінності Майдану
як активна позиція, як солідарність.
Дітей треба любити, а все решта додається в ході.
Ну, звичайно, що працювати з ними.
Ми дуже багато малювали, читали, співали,
ввечері були колискові постійно.
Дуже любили вони театр, ляльковий театр,
у нас кожна неділя — похід у театр, коли було двоє дітей.
А так: англійська, танці, «Пласт».
Дуже багато їм дав «Пласт».
Я думаю, що всім дітям багато дав «Пласт».
Звичайно, вдома виховання таке було сімейне,
дуже родинне, батьки,
і байдарки, на яких ми плавали вечорами,
постійно співали.
Вертепи в нас постійно,
не переставали ходити в селі.
У нас був просто вертеп зі своїх дітей:
наших було п'ятеро, і брата було двоє дітей.
Був такий вертеп, де були самі ангелики,
тобто всі діти — всі ангелики.
І вони придумували собі таку творчість,
креативність, самі придумували собі сценарій.
Навіть на репетиції нас не кликали.
«Не заходьте! Побачите готовий вертеп!»
Щоб ми не могли вже нічого скоригувати.
Вертепи були дуже цікаві.
Конкуренція, можливо, є.
Але є таке, власне, що казали,
що всі рівняються на Юрка.
І кожен не хоче бути, не те, що нижчим,
але вони задали планку,
що треба вчитися, треба багато пізнавати.
Це наша найбільша радість — цей балкон.
Ми тут улітку завжди вчимося,
спимо, влітку тут завжди зорі видно.
Ну, я думаю, що тут класно, що у нас трава,
ми з будь-якого поверху виходимо на газони.
Тут ми завжди замірюємо,
хто має який зріст кожного року,
і ми так, від не знаю, від скількох років
нас тут міряли, звідси, ще Ганнуся написано.
І ми завжди мірялися, і змагалися
хто швидше кого переросте.
Це було для нас якесь таке,
в дитинстві, зараз уже ні,
було дуже важливо вирости якнайшвидше.
Це наша кімната: моя і Марти.
Не знаю, насправді,
ми як закінчили Академію лідерства,
ми сюди приїхали, у нас була стара кімната
з такими дитячими меблями.
Ми захотіли з Мартою зробити ремонт,
і все винести.
Це був наш такий перший
із Мартою проєкт — наша кімната.
Ми продали меблі, заробили перші такі гроші.
Нам тато зробив цей стіл, поки ми на БУРі були.
Ми були два тижні на БУРі,
тато сказав, що раз ми будуємо країну,
він нам сам зробить стіл і цей ремонт трошки.
Матріарх сім'ї нашої — бабця.
Пані бабця. Стояти струнко!
[сміються]
Бабця Дозя завжди була
патріотичних позицій.
У нас виникла така ідея: зробити
соціальний бренд із бабцею Дозею, за її згодою,
щоб вона була транслятором
цінності нашої сім'ї, і такої проактивної позиції.
[молються перед вживанням їжі]
Колись, як ми були дітьми,
то кожного вечора стабільно збиралися,
ми визначили годину: десята чи одинадцята,
усі в той час мали бути вдома, і спільно молилися.
Я думаю, це традиція,
яка нас найбільше об'єднала, — спільна молитва.
Бо ми завжди були разом,
говорили якісь важливі для нас речі.
Це і про цінності такі християнські,
але вони і загальнолюдські,
які нас так тато виховував,
пояснював якісь важливі речі,
про які ми там, можливо б,
не задумувались, якби не ця молитва,
читання Біблії спільне,
і обговорення кожного вечора.
♪ [співають пісню Океан Ельзи «Не питай»] ♪
Рясне — це один із найбільших
спальних районів Львова —
то це фактично околиця міста,
де живе дуже багато людей,
але де майже відсутні будь-які заклади
для культурного дозвілля.
Тому стратегічно важливим
для нашої фундації було відкрити тут родинний центр,
який відкрився фактично майже рік тому.
Тобто це нове приміщення,
ми збудували його з нуля,
придумували власну концепцію,
дизайн, зонування.
Простір, який дає можливість
місцевим мешканцям не їхати в центр,
щоб віддати дитину на якийсь гурток:
англійська мова чи танці, чи співи.
А все, щоб було локально.
Загалом, він теж є соціальним підприємництвом,
тому що, наприклад, сім'ї, які мають можливість
заплатити за це, вони платять ринкову ціну.
Коштом цього, сім'ям,
які не мають можливості заплатити,
тобто певним пільговим категоріям,
ми надаємо ці послуги безкоштовно.
Першою є сама машина, яка тягне БУРмобіль,
а це є власне причіп, який ми
трансформували в повноцінну майстерню.
Тут є всі інструменти, необхідні для того,
щоб заїхати в повністю ізольоване місце,
і там розкинути генератор, робити електрику,
і під'єднуются інструменти, і ми можемо
з нуля створити громадський простір,
або з нуля зробити молодіжний центр.
Тобто, по суті, це повноцінна майстерня,
яка дає технічну можливість для того,
щоб втілювати такі урбаністичні
проєкти в будь-якому місці.
Це основна територія, яка дає можливість
працювати ззовні, не заходячи всередину.
Тут є можливість витягнути
будь-який потрібний інструмент,
починаючи від шліфмашин
і закінчуючи дрельками, шуроповертами,
болгарками, пилками і т.д.
Майстерня — дуже мультифункціональна,
і от зараз наш шефкухар Сява робить бурітоси.
Ми, у принципі, заїжджаючи в якесь місто,
намагаємось використовувати різні інструменти,
щоб спілкуватися з місцевими мешканцями.
І ми, окрім того, що робимо майстерню,
також намагаємось створити
якесь місце для трапези,
бо під час харчування теж можна
класно взаємодіяти.
І ми цього року експериментуємо з бурітосами.
БУР, буріто. У нас така ніби гра слів.
І ми вирішили робити здорову їжу,
і її за благодійні внески також продавати,
і так намагатися заробляти на наш проєкт.
Це наш один із перших волонтерів БУРу,
і співзасновник БУРу, можна сказати,
тому що перший наш табір відбувався
в Краматорську Донецької області.
Тоді ми з командою Львівської освітньої фундації,
у якій ми працювали, поїхали в Краматорськ.
Разом із місцевими мешканцями, на чолі з Колею,
відбудовували перші будинки.
Завдяки спільній будові, спільній допомозі людям,
створилась дуже класна така тусовка.
На базі тієї тусовки ми створили перший
в Україні молодіжний центр «Вільна хата».
Коля є засновником і
координатором «Вільної хати» до сьогодні.
Я не один, нас троє, як мінімум.
І ми в процесі туру отримали дуже багато запитів на те,
щоб БУРмобіль приїжджав в інші міста,
допомагав створювати громадські простори,
допомагав узагалі взаємодіяти з містом.
Тому, можливо, ми будемо цей БУРмобіль
перетворювати в окремий підпроєкт БУРу,
який буде просто на запити місцевих команд
заїжджати і створювати в місті [простір].
Як вчора нам сказали:
«Швидка будівельна допомога».
[сміються]
Так-так.
Я мав можливість близько 3,5 років
жити у США, вчитися і працювати.
Мені там було комфортно матеріально,
але я там не відчував себе вдома.
У мене завжди була чітка відповідь,
я завжди хотів жити тут.
У принципі, щоб жити тут адекватно, і почуватися
комфортно не тільки емоційно, але і матеріально,
є величезний шмат роботи, який треба зробити.
І цього ніхто не зробить, окрім нас.
В Україні є багато крутих людей,
які потребують підсилення.
І ми трактуємо свою програму,
свою фундацію,
як інструмент підсилення
відповідальних, активних людей.
То ми їздимо містами України,
шукаємо цікавих, потенційно сильних людей,
їх нашою компетентністю, ресурсами,
підтримкою трохи підштовхуємо,
і вони вже є тими «агентами змін на місцях».
Тому в мене є чітке розуміння,
чітка впевненість у тому,
що те, що ми робимо має величезне значення.
У нас ще років 20 роботи попереду,
щоб досягти того рівня життя в країні,
у якій хочеться жити.
У мене є дуже сильні амбіції
жити в класній країні, і тому я це роблю.